[Music]
in the third episode of strange new
worlds a costume from an unaired pilot
makes a reappearance and the events of
an old star trek book become canonized
here are all the other easter eggs you
may have missed
in the third episode ghosts of valyria
the enterprise visits an illyrian colony
on an alien world according to number
one's log entry which opens the episode
the colony has been abandoned with no
explanation and they are there to
discover why she also describes
illyrians as a race of people who use
genetic modifications to enhance their
capabilities and levels of function but
the illyrians are not a new species to
star trek having appeared once before in
a third season episode of enterprise
titled damage that episode took place in
the midst of the season's zindy war arc
and saw captain archer encounter an
elyrian vessel while his ship was badly
damaged the illyrians were also in
distress so archer offered to help but
he wanted a warp coil in return the
enterprise's warp drive had been
rendered non-functional and without a
new one they would be unable to stop the
zindy from completing their mission to
wipe out earth denied by the illyrians
who can't afford to go without a warp
drive either the story sees archer
grapple with the moral decision of
whether or not to steal it in order to
save billions of lives in ghosts of
illyria the one illyrium we do see is
identical to a human while the illyrians
in damage had a series of unusual
cranial ridges of course given their
practice of genetic modifications it's
anyone's guess what illyrians look like
naturally
in episode 3 a landing party is sent to
the illyrian colony to investigate we
see pyke oona spock and a handful of
enterprise officers looking for anything
that might point to why the colony was
abandoned our first clue is a massive
electrical storm on the horizon the away
team is dressed for the occasion
sporting dark gray duty jackets over
their more colorful classic uniforms
it's a cool look but it's also an easter
egg we saw something similar in star
trek the original series the grey
landing party jackets appeared to be a
nod to the overcoats worn by the away
team in the cage the original pilot
episode
in the cage pike spock and the rest of
the landing party sports similar codes
during their away mission to a planet in
the tallow system which has been
broadcasting a distress signal the
rejected pilot episode wasn't seen in
full until it was released on vhs as
part of the 20th anniversary
celebrations in 1986 though footage from
it did appear in the original series
episode the menagerie which flashed back
to the events of tallow's iv the jacket
scene and ghost of illyria are a clear
callback with the design updated for the
new series offering crew members better
protection and hostile environments
chief of security la'anna nooni in singh
shares a well-known last name with one
of the biggest baddies in star trek
history khan noonian singh best known as
the nemesis of captain kirk in the film
star trek 2 the wrath of khan this
famous villain first appeared in the
original series episode space seed where
it's revealed that he was one of the
genetically engineered tyrants who
plunged earth into chaos during the
eugenics war of the 1990s put in
suspended animation he was brought back
in the 23rd century where he battled
kirk in the aforementioned episode and
again in the second star trek film
following his first defeat in ghost of
illyria it's revealed that la'an is
indeed a descendant of khan though it's
heavily implied that she has none of the
genetic superiority of her ancestor she
seems to harbor at least some resentment
over her heritage having been bullied in
her youth by those who learns that she
was related to one of earth's worst
historical madmen it seems that augment
was a common playground in salt used
against her a nod to khan
a key plot point in ghosts of illyria is
a federation's ban on genetic
modifications it's mentioned that after
the eugenics was earth and later
starfleet and the federation placed a
ban on genetic engineering and so-called
augments it's also confirmed that those
who are genetically engineered or
modified in any way cannot serve in
starfleet once again this directly
references the original series episode
spaceseed but it also recalls several
star trek deep space nine episodes
involving julian bashir the show's
resident chief medical officer in the
episode dr bashir i presume it's
revealed that bashir was in fact
genetically modified as a child born
with mental and physical challenges his
parents arranged for genetic tampering
turning him into a genius and elite
athlete he's forced to hide his true
nature to maintain his career in
starfleet but the truth is
i'm a fraud
you're not a fraud
i don't care how many enhancements your
parents had done when he's discovered
he's threatened with expulsion until his
father surrenders himself to authorities
and strikes a bargain to allow bashir to
stay in service this parallels the story
of number one it's funny how genetic
modification still puts everyone on edge
in ghosts of illyria she acknowledges
that she like bashir is in fact
genetically modified once again a
prominent star trek cast member must
face the consequences of their genetic
status but she doesn't need to worry
pike promises to keep her secret because
she is the best first officer in the
fleet
a deadly virus is sweeping through the
ship and ghosts of illyria which is why
number one feels compelled to reveal her
genetic origins the illyrium believes
her genetically modified blood could
provide a cure but dr umbenga explains
that he's not allowed to use allerian
blood for medical purposes when the
doctor catches a virus and prepares
himself for sedation he has a heart to
heart with number one regarding the
blood ban and how intolerance throughout
history has held back medical science in
classic star trek fashion they talk of
prejudice and bigotry of how fear of
those who are different has never gone
away even after humans have put aside
their differences on earth they simply
found new neighbors on different planets
to hate he cites the reaction towards
the mixing of human and vulcan blood a
direct reference to the events of star
trek enterprise in a two-part story
spread across the episodes demons and
terror prime we met a group of humans on
earth around a century before strange
new worlds who feared the mixing of
human and vulcan dna they were willing
to kill to prevent the two races from
promote the intermingling degradation of
mankind by encouraging alien human
relations while humanity has gotten past
that hatred by the time of strange new
worlds their shunning of illyrians
proves they still have a long way to go
during the climax of ghosts of illyria
oona admits that she is allerian and is
genetically modified like most of her
kind as we know she kept this secret
because of the federation's ban on
genetic modifications what fans and
viewers might not know however is that
this was already established in the star
trek expanded universe of novels it's
mentioned in the book vulcan's glory
published in 1989. in that book written
by original series writer dc fontana we
learned that number one's name is una
but it's said that this is not a real
illyrian name in the book her heritage
is no secret and her real name is not
pronounceable by humans instead she took
the name una meaning one her moniker
number one was not meant to signify her
rank as the first officer but rather
highlight the fact that she was the best
of her kind of course this hasn't been
made official but if strange new worlds
has pulled her illyrian ancestry into
play anything is possible
after the crisis aboard the ship has
been solved in ghosts of illyria number
one arrives in the sick bay to confront
doctor and benga about the cause it
seems that the emergency transporters in
the ship sickbay weren't updated in
space dock at umbenga's insistence this
resulted in a malfunction that allowed
an infectious disease to get past the
system's biofilters which normally
screen out foreign toxins viruses and
dangerous bacteria number one realizes
why when she analyzes hema's diagnostic
reports of the sickbay transporters dr
umbenga is keeping someone or something
alive in the transporter buffer this is
when we learn umbenga secret his
daughter was diagnosed with a
devastating terminal illness and he soon
realized that the only way to save her
was to keep her pattern circulating
within the transporter buffer did you
know there's no limit
on how long you can store someone's
pattern in the buffer well trekkies do
know because they've seen it before in
the next generation episode relics the
enterprise d crew meets the original
enterprises chief engineer scotty who
did the same thing to stay alive for
more than 70 years we know scotty and
umbenga will eventually serve together
in the years that follow this episode
perhaps scotty learned the trick from
the savvy physician
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]